hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to inside now we're
gonna find out where these guys are
going I'm not a Hummer senator I want to
know oh there we go okay
a bird flew by just as I did that oh man
why can't I Boosh away I'm not good at
the pull oh well I guess that's all
right then can I go down now thank you
alright so where am I going and why was
i hearing a heartbeat out there but it's
kind of muffled in here it seems bad
okay so where am I now and why am i
descending into the sewers it seems like
a bad thing but then again I don't
really know what's good for me so I'm
gonna keep going forward
hit me nope that didn't work maybe I got
to push it from the other side no yeah
I'm too smart for you I'm too smart for
you me am big brain have and do smart
good okay
whoa what is that oh oh oh man that
startled that guy on the ground
apparently Oh God
whoo wait he's got a wire on him why did
I turn that on that seems like it was a
bad move rock oh I just did a video with
the rock you can see it I'll put a link
in the description but it's over on his
channel that he just started because he
wanted to start a YouTube channel which
is really admirable like I'm actually
impressed that he would be interested
anyway but yes so maybe it has any of
you ever seen the video of that what
happens if I just don't turn him on oh
yeah this is much better
oh this is much better oh okay so I just
goofed
I just goofed real hard oh boy so I got
open this and then turn
and then go through it all but there's a
video of the rock from this wrestling
days funny what I do it but I I swear
it's really funny like you it's like
guaranteed to cheer you up on the
darkest of days ha you can't get me you
light flinging bastard I don't know who
made you but you are goddamn bizarre
anyway so go to look that up it's really
funny it's just I believe the video
title is just called can you smell what
The Rock is cooking but I'm not I wasn't
sure and I think they actually quote is
if you smell what The Rock is cooking
what you got over there little birdy
bird I'm gonna take it from you oh that
don't seem good hmm something seems bad
it's getting pretty stressful in here
that's my [ __ ] oh sorry what did I do
Oh God well that's not good don't mind
me I'm fine ah I am dude or
smart smart kid smart smart smart smart
smart kid this kid's so smart
oh do do do did twitch can i twitch ah
god I'm trying to twitch
now I'm twitching too much oh I see okay
well I mean I already saw but I'm just
gonna do it less stupidly this time but
keep your head down son what are you
doing and stop yeah you ain't see
nothing with me I am normal I'm normal
human normal everyday will stolen human
normal everyday puppet in a gosh-darn
human skin bag everyday human
why are we stopping why are you still
looking at me I'm not suspicious stop
staring you creep oh boy okay
see good see good oh I got a jack gonna
jump okay
oh this is gonna go well oh this is
gonna go really well
oh boy oh boy oh okay we got it
I know what I'm doing I know what I'm
doing even though I'm a different color
no one seems to be perturbed
I didn't mean god damn and I that was my
fault that's not yeah that's not my
fault
nor did no one pay any attention to me
I'm terrible I know I don't know I'm
terrible I'm aware yeah trip bend you
okey-dokey then
shop but open ah everyone is so
impressed shrimp okay [ __ ] up shop chump
okay I'm out of that Jeb Abdul do
whatever I gotta do to impress you
okay all right I can do that I can do
that I've already been good at all these
things I just didn't do it at the right
time
ship ship okay I'm the master this
I think I can get out of here I don't
need to be in the next batch yeah I
don't look at the camera kid it's not
gonna help you at all all right oh oh we
good are we good okay I think we're good
whoo that was a creepy boy that sounds
bad
is that our inevitable fate that work
marching towards oh no oh okay probably
because I just wasn't supposed to be
over there oh the cameras still looking
at me maybe I got to make a break for it
if I got to make a break for it oh boy
okay I'm [ __ ] out of here oh gosh you
came too close
hi how's it going friends how you doing
you faceless bastards oh yeah beautiful
faceless mass
Oh goddammit idea I stopped I was not
aware that I needed to that's a lot of
death happened and that's a lot of death
oh he's so proud of what he's done I'm
not though ok so there's got to be like
I obviously can't beat him there so
there's something else to be done where
are you going oh god damn it I almost
faked you out I almost Oh
[Laughter]
okay third time's a charm a lot of death
happening but you no need to worry about
it it's fine totally fine you ready all
right get ready for the most epic fake
out of terminology the world how the
[ __ ] goddamn that's not I wasn't
supposed to happen that uh that wasn't
supposed to happen
that was the opposite of where were
supposed to happen I don't know why that
happened that time and not the other
time but maybe okay yeah hope oh okay
now we can make it ha ha ha ha
you're so stupid okay push me push me oh
hey come back here can you come back
your boost me okay bye-bye you weird dog
or hope you get infected with worm was
okay boy that's got to put a lot of
strain on this kid's neck to be attached
to this so gloriously you heard me
precariously okay bye buddy
you've had good time you'd be good I why
am I not boosting this Boosh ah oh wait
but it's a catch okay so I gotta be back
over there
didn't know how to no that's what I get
for trying to boost to early man I was
just so ready to Boosh I finally got an
opportunity I just had no idea what I
needed to do grab
and boom okay let go I'll be back you
have fun take care I still hear that
stupid dog in the distance but I don't
need to worry about him I just need to
worry about what I'm doing over your
okay God mom away hope you didn't go
anywhere a good buddy mmm okay starting
to look a little better but I imagine
this whole city has been taken over by
some sort of what I can only assume is
alien menace I'm not sure about that but
I can only assume because I'm stupid and
by assuming things I make it uh novice
that I'm on intelligence if those
goddamn words made any bit of sense I
don't need to be this far and this was a
horrible air or why do I need to be over
there there's something above that so
there's something up there but how can I
get up there is the question no there's
something definitely up there and down
would only be death oh of course I'm
actually controlling the guy I forgot
that I was actually controlling him
which means that there is whoa there's
like a second helmet what happens if I
what happens if there's two guys in a
helmet oh oh
double puppet activities going on here
hey that is frankly pretty dang weird
okay
that is bizarre the music even got a
little more interesting about it but
what can I do about this so if I now
drop out of I'm oh I know what I need to
do I need to have this over here so
whoops don't be dead please so I can I
can drop myself over here he can still
climb up here drop out of there
I can get this back he can come back and
we can keep going thank you buddy you
just taking me up there you're doing a
wonderful job and I really appreciate
everything that you've done to help me
thus far you're an amazing person
although I don't know what benefit this
technology does when you have to do the
exact movements that the others doing
like it does it's not exactly anything
besides I guess a force multiplier but
only if you're doing the exact same
thing many times across well that's
probably surprising to them boo-ki okay
do I drop down there I think I drop down
there and I got I got there very worried
about this they'll be extremely worried
in just a hot second when I'm actually
able to do a son of a [ __ ] about this
stupid thing now that this is due but
I'm just saying I'm stupid for not being
smart about it which is all the every
day of my life goodbye goodbye goodbye
goodbye bloosh oh I bet this water is
fun and definitely hygienic it need air
choke down my own spit sorry okay so
what is this do I need to do I saw this
in the corner a blue ski good thing it
was colored because otherwise I wouldn't
have known about it oh that's awesome
but what does that mean do I need the
proofs to do silver here do I finally
need to do something okay that's a guy
damn it stop being stupid stop being a
silly Billy for once in your life and
boost the damn thing reminds me of when
I was playing The Last of Us and Ellie
needed to get in the goddamn pallet my
last dying wish just be a goddamn friend
alright here we go
got it I figured out the puzzle cuz I'm
smart and I have brain big who else is
here who else is going try murder me
besides everyone which is the main
problem Oh button I'll press it right
away huh boy
oh is that a good thing no good this
seems excellent Oh bartend I'll push
that to the boy so that was nice Oh - hi
- hi
oh just high enough can I leap out of
the water like a fish
okay so there's got to be something that
I can push onto the water that's gonna
help me reach that chain so there's got
to be something around here somewhere
nope just kidding you fake you up
alright so that gets me back in here ooh
I'm tired
so all this would do is this would reset
the water level which is exactly what I
just did so it would only lower the
water level which I don't think actually
helps me because all I did was just get
back into this area so that door is open
now oh wait a minute if there's a way to
flood this area if I can somehow break
the system I can keep the doors open and
flood them but I don't know if that's
proper or way of going about it so there
is a way
yeah cuz these doors they closed
automatically when the water level rises
so there must be some way oh I know I
gotta go get um I gotta go get something
from the other room because it's got to
be because when this is here that means
the other door opens right no goddamnit
okay I'm officially stuck for the first
time in this game I'm stuck so there's
gotta be something obvious I'm missing
what if I what if I hit the button from
here
I just swim down and hit the button and
try to get to the upper ledge before
that happens
hey there we go okay that did it well
that was good enough but what did I it's
dark in here
ah that is that is ominous that is what
one would call ominous oh but I got this
I don't know how I got it but I got it
okay so I got this and if I pull this
out do I need to build [ __ ] I finally
need to boost some for once in my
goddamn life okay we got this no drop
down bushi BuChE BuChE BuChE BuChE you
abyss you all the way outside and then
when you're outside you'll actually be
floating and you'll be able to get me
where I need to go but the thing is I
need it now you're fine there so why
would I ever need to go back into the
place there must be something for the
future like I just don't understand it
right now yeah it would have been
terrible if this thing didn't actually
float there we go okay and then up and
then where does this go hi don't mind me
once again wow that seems like normal
society why is everyone a zombie maybe
that's just the lower labor force man
isn't this kid getting - oh my god oh my
god that's a lot of people
that's a lot of people really that's
lovely the way that that shadow moves
tonight Oh God it's fine
I just didn't know exactly what I needed
to do before I started doing it so you
know that is a huge line of people oh
man that's too many people remind me a
halflife city seventeen in the lovely
world that Deborah [ __ ] [ __ ] ass ow my
spine well every part of me broke but
that's fine because I'll be getting uh
getting along Wow I messed up my hair
royally but no one pay attention to that
everyone pay attention to the amazing
skill that's about to be seen in front
of you today oh that's what I call skill
baby that's what I call skill I'm hooked
on skill yeah it skill the skill here
it's skill inator to Skillman de it's
skill hard day yeah ground skill day I
don't know I can't think of clever
things while I'm on the fly okay okay I
made it what good does this do me oh
that's how good jeez good thing I
dropped all the way to the box the box
is my safety net I love the box the box
is the bells okay come on baggy or
whatever the hell you are you're
obviously not a helicopter so you're
just a monitoring station on the roofs
for some reason like why would they need
to have a great big searchlight here on
the roof just seems counterintuitive
counterintuitive gutter incentive whoa
we made it maybe there was a secret over
there on the right but I doubt I could
have gotten all the way over there so
for now I'm gonna count my blessings and
just stay over here I'm gonna make it I
made it I'm gonna make it I'm gonna make
it Oh
I made it I'm gonna make it I'm gonna
make it what the hell is going on over
oh nothing I'm gonna make it I'm gonna
make it oh okay
down we go whoo this looks bad
whoa aah that's where that train wins
okay what is that noise there's noises
here
I don't like noise noises is bad this is
bad man
I mean so far there's nothing
supernatural going on in here but it's
there's dago's oh I see some door goes
over there there's some Naga who's how
you doing buddies you doing good good to
know there's still rampant electricity
running through all these old decrepit
tube trains and that there's dago's
chewing on something that must be some
sort of a fresh kill all bad every every
of this is bad don't spot me whatever
you do if you spot me I swear I'm gonna
smack you upside your head okay
ah man these dago's
okay bye he's on to something
not me but he's on to something okay
nothing down here nothing down here
nothing down here
doesn't look like nothing down here okay
okay so that dog Oh ran over here
I have a funny feeling that was possible
I had no idea
maybe if I dive Rudy you can't get me
I'm too deep I'm too deep oh oh I should
have gotten far I should have gotten
farther in I should have gotten father
and I got more he's better getting a
pool in cheek I was fine war seems bad
pulled off pulled off oh I said it just
crawled under I would have been smarter
I should have just danced with them back
and forth and pulled off one more hole
that's bad or that looks bad one board
at a time see what'd I tell you at the
beginning of this I would have found all
the ways to die okay so I just got to
get one board okay go go go go go buddy
go stupid dogs it's so stupid
look how stupid you are what about your
Stoops down oh so dumb so dumb so dumb
hello come get me pops
come get me hahaha fresh meat for the
eating you silly [ __ ] okay we're good
so far yeah this should be enough okay
through through through you're okay
we're good I was a victory burp right
there
whoo-hoo Nelly okay so that is probably
all the time that I got for this episode
thank you everybody so much for watching
that was a bit of a crisis to get
through there but I got it there
expertly because of just how brave I am
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]